bonjour et bienvenue aujourd'hui pour
cette fois en question stop shirt ou une
fois n'est pas coutume vous allez voir
ma trombine car comme vous l'aurez
compris j'ai des tas de têtes de mort à
vous montrer la question du jour ça va
être toumaï était-il un gorille ou
plutôt tout mac
appartient-il à la famille d'ego reid
alors cette vidéo elle va faire suite à
une autre vidéo que j'ai réalisée sur le
thème lucie et elle a pas besoin et que
je vous invite à voir en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaîtra alors pourquoi
m'intéresser à la question to my
était-il à gori et bien tout simplement
parce que c'est une question qui m'a été
posée de nombreuses fois y compris par
des gens qui ont un certain bagage
scientifique en matière de paléontologie
c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est une rumeur
qui court dans les milieux
paléontologique et dont personne ne
semble réellement avoir la réponse
alors pour vous j'ai remonté la piste de
cette rumeur et j'ai retrouvé du où elle
sortait en fait cette rumeur et vient de
deux articles qui ont été écrits par des
spécialistes des grands singes parmi ces
deux articles il ya un article qui est
très détaillé et l'autre qui est
beaucoup plus court alors je ne vous
parlerai aujourd'hui que de l'article
détaillé puisque l'article le plus court
est parue dans une revue à plus large
diffusion ne fait que reprendre en
détaillant beaucoup moins les arguments
qui ont été développés dans l'article le
plus long la première chose intéressante
avec cet article c'est qu'il a été écrit
par une équipe surtout composée de
spécialistes des grands singes mais pas
des homininés la raison pour laquelle
cet intéressant c'est que ça explique
déjà en partie pourquoi ces gens pensent
que toumaï pourrait être un gorille
plutôt qu'un homininés en effet si on
regarde le registre fossile des grands
singes et notamment des grands sages du
milieu scène une période qui s'étend de
environ moins 20 millions d'années à
environ
5 millions d'années eh bien on remarque
que ces grands singes sont très très
abondant le registre fossile des grands
singes est très très riches jusqu'à
moins 5 millions d'années et très
bizarrement à une période comprise entre
environ - 7 millions d'années et moins 5
millions d'années eh bien les grands
singes se font de plus en plus rares
tandis que les hominidés donc toumaï par
exemple font leur apparition et le
registre fossile des homininés et
curieusement très très riches au moment
le registre fossile des grands sages
commence à péricliter à devenir de moins
en moins riches il y a deux
interprétations possibles à cela soit
l'apparition des homininés a conduit à
la quasi disparition des grands sages
puisqu'il n'en reste plus aujourd'hui
que les gorilles les chimpanzés et les
orangs outans soit et c'est là
qu'interviennent les spécialistes des
grands sages des homininés très anciens
comme toumaï pourrait en fait ne pas
être des homininés mais être de simples
grands singes non humains et dans ce cas
ça expliquerait pourquoi les homininés
apparaissent dans le registre fossile
pile au moment où les grands singes
commencent à disparaître dans cet
article n'est pas des primatologues vont
donc essayer de montrer que les
caractères qui ont permis d'interpréter
tous mike en mettant à nominer ne sont
pas valides et que par conséquent tout
bail est un primates non humains mais il
ya un gros problème avec cette démarche
et il n'est pas des moindres c'est que
pour eux parvenir à rejeter l'hypothèse
que cinq d'entre eux plus cet anneau
midi n'est fait par définition de side
entre aux bus un grand singe or ce
raisonnement est totalement faux puisque
qu'une seule d'entre eux pu ce soit ou
non un nominé ça et notre puce est un
conte sage puisque l'homme est lui même
un grand sac
il n'existe pas d'opposition entre les
grands sages d'à côté
humain de l'autre si vous parvenez à
démontrer que celle entre opus ne
partage pas de caractère avec les
homininés alors vous n'avez que
démontrer que ça une entrevue ce n'est
pas un hominidé vous n'avez pas démontré
que ça et d'entre eux puce est proche
parent du moring ou bien du ch à penser
ça pourrait tout aussi bien vouloir dire
que tout maïs se trouve à la base de
cette bifurcation qui amenait d'à côté
au chapeau rejet de l'autre à l'homme
et s'il se trouve à cet endroit là ils
dénient h imposé ni un homme il est
autre chose mais en aucun cas ça fait de
lui un gorille ou un chimpanzé pour que
celle entre opus soit proche parent du
gorille ou du chimpanzé il faut lui
trouver des caractères de chimpanzés ou
de gorille donc de base
l'article commence dès l'introduction en
nous expliquant qu'ils vont essayer de
démontrer que toumaï est un grand sage
est un gorille ou et tâches imposées
simplement en démontrant qu'il n'est pas
un humain alors déjà commençons par
énoncer les caractères qui font 2 to buy
side entre puces a nominé
le premier de ces caractères c'est la
petite taille de la canine aussi les
facettes d'usure qui se trouvent ici
montre que la canine s'user par
l'arrière et par le sommet et non pas
par l'avant comme chez les sacs donc
grâce à l'usure des canines et même si
nous n'avons pas la mâchoire de toumaï
il est possible de dire que les cabines
du dessus venait s'imbriquer devant les
canines du dessous exactement comme chez
nous alors que si vous regardez le
sourire dagory vous verrez que les
canines du dessous viennent devant les
canines du dessus est du coup l'usure
des canines du 2
ce fait par le devant chez toumaï les
canines sont usés par l'arrière et par
le sommet chez les grands singes et les
singes les canines sont usés par le
devant et c'est quelque chose qui se
voit très bien chez le babouin
enfin troisième caractère qui fait que
toumaï serait un homme d'idées et bien
c'est la position du trot occipital
c'est à dire du trou pour l'entrée de la
moelle épinière dans le cerveau qui est
située sous le crâne exactement comme
chez les hominidés
ce qui signifie que la moelle épinière
rentrée n'ont pas à l'horizontale dans
le crabe et ce qui veut dire que la
colonne vertébrale n'était pas
positionnée à l'horizontale mais que la
moelle épinière rentrée par le dessous
du grade et que la colonne vertébrale et
est donc situé à la verticale sur le
crâne
cela signifie donc que toumaï était
bipède et les singes bipèdes ce sont les
hommes ni plus ni moins alors que quand
on regarde ici l'un des babouins et bien
le trou est situé légèrement plus vers
l'arrière du crâne
ce qui signifie que la moelle épinière
vente est plus à l'horizontale qu'à la
verticale
oui mais voilà les auteurs de l'article
dont je vous parle aujourd'hui on fait
très justement remarquer que tous ces
caractères n'était pas si évident que ça
par l'occurrence vous aurez remarqué que
la position du trou occipital en dessous
du crade et quand même très similaire
chez les sages et chetumal et cela
dépend largement de la façon dont vous
tenez le crap ensuite la petite taille
de la canine se retrouve chez d'autres
grands sages du miocène et contemporain
de toumaï comme aurait évité cuche aura
copie tqs ou encore s'il va piquer cus
et il ne s'agirait donc pas d'une
caractéristique complètement propre au
genre humain aussi l'usure applicables
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure et qui
montreraient donc tout bas il avait un
sourire humain n'est pas un sous couvert
de gorilles elle arrive aussi parfois
accidentellement chez d'autres grands
singes et en particulier elle est
présente chez le très célèbre gigan de
pittacus le grand sage géant de ski
donc tous ces caractères qui font de
toumaï à nominer ne sont pas
complètement propre aux homininés on les
retrouve chez d'autres grands sages
séparément c'est juste qu'un
combinaisons qu'il ferait que toumaï
serait à nominer et le dernier problème
qui est soulevée par ses auteurs c'est
aussi que tous ces caractères se
retrouve chez les juvéniles de sage
vous pouvez voir ici un babouin juvénile
alors déjà je vous laisse apprécier la
ressemblance qu'il existe entre les
juvéniles de singe non humains et les
juvéniles humain vous voyez ici
cette boîte crânienne très développée
avec une face voyez relativement courte
vous noterez aussi l'absence de
bourrelets au dessus de leurs beats
exactement comme chez les humains
modernes donc les juvéniles de singe
ressemble énormément à des adultes
humain et en ce qui concerne toumaï et
bien qu'est ce qu'on a on a ici chez les
juvéniles de sages des canines qui sont
relativement réduite
exactement comme sur la femelle
d'ailleurs donc tout mari pourrait tout
aussi bien pour ce caractère être à
juvénile beau être une femelle est aussi
vous avez la position du trou aussi
billy talent donc de l'entrée damon
épinière qui se trouve en dessous
beaucoup plus vers l'avant que chez les
adultes
donc tous ces caractères pourrait tout
aussi bien s'expliquer par le fait que
toumaï serait un jeune et vous l'aurez
compris tout l'interprétation selon
laquelle ça et d'autres opus donc toumaï
serait à nominer repose sur le fait que
cet individu qui est le seul connu est
un adulte
alors qu'est ce qui fait que dubaï est
interprété comme un individu adulte et
bien déjà la dentition on peut observer
chez toumaï que la dent de sagesse c'est
à dire la troisième molaire celles qui
ne pousse qu'une fois à l'âge adulte est
sorti chez toumaï elle a poussé et elle
est déjà usé
donc ça veut dire que tout
était déjà adulte quand il est mort
ensuite vous pouvez observer ici le
bourg les supras orbitaire qui est cette
sorte de sourcils au saut par dessus des
orbites et bien se bourrer les eaux se
on le retrouve aussi chez les singes
donc ici chez les babouins ici chez
australopithèques us en fait aux mots
est le seul grand singe à ne pas avoir
de pour les osseuse au dessus des
orbites et bien se bourrer les eaux se
est extrêmement une paix pouvait voir
qu'il est très développé ce qui est un
signe qu'on est face à un mal puisque
les mâles ont généralement le beau léo
se veut bien plus développée que les
femelles
ici donc pour toutes ces raisons toumaï
est interprétée comme étant d'une part à
l'individu adultes et d'autre part un
individu mâle ce qui rend très
significatif
la petite taille des canines puisque les
mâles sages sont censés normalement a
pas de grandes canines sauf les zones
minées et cela rend aussi plus
significatif la position du trou
occipital par dessus le crac puisque
toumaï n'est pas unanime
alors maintenant dans l'hypothèse où
dubaï serait à gori il faudrait
évidemment en premier lieu admettre que
toumaï des bases un adulte mâle ce qui
n'écarterait du coût de la lignée des
homininés et ensuite il faudrait lui
trouver un caractère qu'il ne partirait
que avec les gorilles
alors ce caractère ça pourrait être
justement la présence de ce très très
fort bourlet supra orbitaire se bourrer
les eaux ce renforcement dos au-dessus
d'orbites parce que quand on regarde en
australie vittek
comme cette australopithecus africanus
et bien on peut remarquer que le
bourrelet supra orbitaire n'est pas
aussi développé que chez toumani il est
beaucoup plus développée chez toumaï que
chez les australopithèques et ça c'est
un caractère que l'on retrouve chez les
gorilles
le problème avec ce caractère c'est que
le bourg les supports biterre est très
prononcé chez les mâles ici chez les
babouins il est encore relativement peu
prononcé par rapport à ce qu'on peut
voir chez les gorilles mais il est
suffisamment pour qu'on puisse voir que
entre les mâles et les femelles il y a
déjà une différence chez les mâles le
bon
et beaucoup plus développé que chez les
femelles et il est encore moins
développée chez les juvéniles chez les
juvéniles
il n'y a même aucun vent les suces
orbitaire et c'est aussi le cas chez les
gorilles donc toumaï dans l'hypothèse où
il serait à gori devrait être un mal
étant donné le fort développement de ce
bol et supra orbitaire or c'est
incompatible avec la petite taille des
canines et la position du trou et
occipital et l'interprétation selon
laquelle toumaï pourrait être un
juvénile de gori n'est de toute façon
pas compatible avec le fait que la
troisième molaire donc la dent de
sagesse a déjà poussé chetumal donc tout
au plus il pourrait s'agir d'une femelle
gorille mais encore une fois ça ne colle
pas avec la taille très prononcé du
bourg les supports orbitaire en
conclusion dans l'état actuel des
connaissances paléontologique sur scène
entre opus c'est à dire le crâne de
toumaï et pas grand chose d'autre
il est plus raisonnable d'interpréter
toumaï comme étant un homme est dit
n'est que comme étant un représentant de
la famille des gorilles pour l'instant
toutes les analyse phylogénétique aussi
rare soient-elles et qui ont pris en
compte tous my les gorilles et parfois
les grands singes du miocène ont
toujours replacer toumaï plus proche des
homininés que des gorille qu'est ce qui
pourrait permettre d'apporter de
nouveaux éléments à cette discussion et
bien déjà le fémur
en effet le jour où thomas il fut
découvert de nombreux zoos ont aussi été
déterrés et en particulier un morceau de
fémur et leur été interprétés comme
pouvant appartenir à al mouminine et le
problème avec ce fragment de fémur c'est
qu'il ne préserve pas de partie très
intéressante les parties intéressant ce
sont les extrémités celle qui s'articule
avec le reste des autres en l'occurrence
cette partie qui s'articule avec le
bassin donc ici vous avez la boule qui
s'articule avec le bassin et si vous
avez cette espèce de crête qu'entre
fémur va s'articuler avec le bassin et
bien cette crête
elle va buter contre le bord du bassin
et empêcher que le feu
soit tenu à la verticale donc ce fémur
de babouins est typiquement un fémur de
quadrupèdes chez les humains cette
crainte est réduite et permet donc au
fémur de prendre une position verticale
la deuxième chose intéressante à voir
sur un fémur c'est la densité osseuse de
cette boule qui s'articule ici avec le
bassin en effet si vous êtes quadrupèdes
la pression va s'exercer ici le poids du
corps va s'appliquer à cet endroit de la
boule est donc cet endroit de la boule
va être plus dense que le reste alors
que si vous êtes vie belle et que vous
tenez votre fémur à la verticale
la pression à s'exercer ici et non pas
là et donc la densité osseuse va être
répartie d'une façon différente chez les
10 pts par rapport au pad ruppen sauf
que le problème de toumaï est bien c'est
que il n'existe rien de cette partie là
on a juste un petit morceau de cette
partie cycle est préservé et ça ça peut
pas vous raconter grand chose
quant à la posture de toumaï et donc
était-il jpeg ou non ce fémur
il a été retrouvé en même temps que to
miles
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il a été retrouvé
avec tout mal je m'explique
en même temps que thomas y ont été
retrouvées non seulement se fera à mon
fémur mais aussi de nombreux fragments
de bovidés en particulier des antilopes
donc ce n'est pas parce que vous
retrouvez à fait mûr d'homininés à côté
du crâne de toumaï que ce fémur
appartient automatiquement à toumaï ce
fémur qu'eux mêmes ne pas avoir
appartenu du tout à celle entre opus
donc quoi que vous parveniez à faire
dire à ce fémur
cela ne s'appliquera pas forcément à
toumaï autre chose mais qui cette fois
pourraient être observées directement
sur le crâne de toumaï c'est son oreille
interne
en effet lors et à terme c'est l'organe
de l' équilibre et elle va donc être
posée
d'une façon très particulière dans votre
tête qui ne sera pas la même
si vous tenez votre corps donc à
l'horizontale ou que vous le donner à la
verticale toumaï l est et reste le plus
ancien de mini n'est connue mais vous
l'aurez compris sa grande ressemblance
avec les singes et notamment avec les
grands sages soulignent à quel point ils
deviennent de plus en plus difficile de
différencier sa job à mesure qu'on
remonte dans le temps et cela parce que
tous partagent ont un ancêtre commun